[Music]
adam humphries jumped from the tampa bay
buccaneers to the tennessee titans in
the offseason as a free agent but he
considered joining the new england
patriots
why didn't humphreys sign with the
patriots well adam humphries is
concerned about a quarterback who is
about to be
42 years of age said humphreys obviously
tom brady's the goat that's that simple
but there's so much that factors into a
decision it was a four-year deal who
knows how many years he's got left
there's a lot that goes into it
ultimately i thought this was coming
here to a team in tennessee that was on
the rise and the young talent on offense
and a really good defense they had
tasted the playoffs i felt like my need
at the slot position was great i felt
like i could contribute and start
something new here slot position is the
key because julian edelman is the guy
who's in charge of the slot in new
england so don't blame it on tom brady
being 42 and frankly chris if i had to
choose between playing with tom brady at
age 42 and pursuing a championship
versus marcus mariota in a contract year
that that quite possibly will end in no
long-term deal for mariota in tennessee
and a new quarterback in 2020 i'm gonna
go with brady 10 out of 10 times sorry
marcus but i'm getting on the
championship train yeah well i i mean i
get it i mean at least for a one-year
decision it's certainly awesome there's
there's no doubt about that now tom
brady's age is probably not the only
factor we're talking about he just gave
you one example that was part of his
decision making and i think that's a
pretty fair uh question first of all i
mean i'm one that'll sit here right now
and tell you if tom brady and the
patriots win the super bowl this year i
think tom brady will retire he'll have
seven super bowls that'll be it so maybe
adam humphries looked at that and said
damn do i really want to do that you
know were the patriots going to pay the
ti to pay the amount of money the titans
were we don't really know that aspect of
it too but mike you made the million
dollar point i mean they got julian
edelman who plays the same position so
what's he want to do share catches with
him and then three years from now when
it's time to get a new contract or go
look your stats aren't that great and
he's gonna go well it's because i got to
share my position with julian edelman so
i think all those things factored into
this uh and i think he felt like okay he
was gonna have more of a significant
role probably with the tennessee titans
where they were gonna feature things
around him where you know to your point
he knows i go up in new england he's
gonna go okay i'm second fiddle to
julian edelman on a lot of these plays
and hey at the very least new england's
not always about just getting their
receivers stats and doing things like
that julian edelman's never had a
thousand yard season you know they're
going to do what they got to do on a
weekly basis to win a football game and
the number one thing the patriots are
right now is a run football team i think
those are probably all part of the the
the decision making for adam humphries
with the tennessee titans but i know
that's a tough one mike because you're
right going to new england brady 42. you
might win a super bowl this year that's
tough to turn down
i think the edelman factor far bigger
than humphreys let on and
and also
it comes down to money as well no doubt
and that's if if i'm tom brady i'm
looking at saying look don't don't don't
pull me into this dude you're making the
decision for a variety of factors don't
don't go oh tommy's old and we don't
know how long he's gonna play and look
here's the thing he's determined to play
until he's 45. i'm intrigued by your
theory and it is rooted in the idea that
when tom brady gets to seven and i think
it's when not if he will surpass michael
jordan with his six nba championships
brady can say i'm the greatest athlete
of all time right and walk off into the
sunset if he would do that who would be
their quarterback next year no i know
and i think those are the things that
probably went through his head he's
going wait so we am i going to go with
brian hoyer you know i mean what's the
moves they're going to make there you
know i understand tom brady has the
drive to play to 45 and i take him at
his word i'm just saying you know you
get beat up one more season at the age
of 42 you win a super bowl let's say you
win the mvp of the super bowl you might
go you know what damn i know i said 45
but how about 42 and a half that's
that's good enough i mean i played long
enough yeah i still think that's uh a
possibility maybe i'm wrong it's total
theory i have no inside info on that hey
and don't diss brian hoyer he will give
you three great games before he gets
injured
everybody that plays quarterback for new
england but i really think that's why
brady wants to play to 45 because he's
afraid that if he leaves belichick with
some other quarterback it's gonna take
some of the luster away from his career
a la joe montana joe montana left man
one year went by and the 49ers were
right back in the nfc championship game
three years in a row and of course won a
super bowl i think that's tom brady's
biggest fear and i think that's why he
is working so hard to stay in playing
shape and play as long as possible again
i don't know this just a theory
but they had steve young that's the
thing there's no steve there's not
lurking behind tom brady and there was
there was a jimmy garoppolo lurking
behind thomas
out of the picture you're right yeah and
and so i it's it's it's just fascinating
to think what kind of a and this falls
into the good problem to have category
if the patriots get to number seven
they'll be very happy about that but if
brady walks away
what do you do right in 2020 i mean that
that will be the story of the offseason
if that happens who will the patriots
quarterback be and will that new
quarterback of the patriots be able to
get it done and will adam humphreys
regret maybe he'll get marcus mariota to
be the next quarterback in new england
patriots and then humphreys can ask for
a trade uh just some fun stuff to
consider but but you know
hey every team's alive every team's got
a chance to win the super bowl in theory
although only a handful actually do and
i think the patriots of the team that
ultimately we're going to be talking
about when february rolls around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports